week and watch for the authors in the
near future on book TB salon.com
co-founder David Talbott is next on book
TV his book the devil's chessboard
focuses on the Dulles brothers Allen
Dulles the longest-serving director of
the CIA and John Foster Dulles Secretary
of State under President Eisenhower
so David a couple announcements to start
off things I think oh no not announced
no but I just a few introductory remarks
maybe to set the stage for our
conversation Patrick and what you want
to introduce me first well this is this
is David Talbott and I'm Patrick marks
is my little shop the green arcade
you've probably been here before or
maybe not and thank you we just
celebrated seven years here and David
has been a part of it actually David was
born in Los Angeles and Locke cabin and
befitting and befitting a legend we
don't know what year that was
but and he you know his father was Lyle
taba Talbot who was an amazing
heartthrob and uh in an actor and
according to his sister Margaret who
wrote this book the Entertainer quite a
guy and it was quite a family and his
brother Steve was also really
interesting guy who was a fantastic
documentary
video maker was very well known for
doing the frontline series and also to
the baby boomers he was known as Gilbert
and Leave It to Beaver yes yes we were a
sitcom family so David was a journalist
he worked during the heyday for
Crawdaddy
wow that's yeah the I remember remembers
cried out of here the great
rock-and-roll magazine Rolling Stone you
probably know a Rolling Stone and editor
at Mother Jones which is still going
doing really well and interviewed David
for the this book The Devil's chess
board and I was at The Examiner and then
he was one of the first people to sort
of say oh my god the internet exists
maybe we can do journalism on it and he
started salon.com
which is still going and is still a
vital organ can I use that word but so
his book season of the witch which you
might know
if I can hold up the prop and yeah
there's several major fans of this book
not only in San Francisco but throughout
the country and this book has recently
been chosen as the one city one book for
the city of San Francisco by the San
Francisco Public Library compulsory that
you read it you must is the law it's on
the Muni bus tells you to read it I mean
you know something's going on then and
then he also was the author of the
best-selling book the brothers and the
brothers which i think is we talked you
know you'd let us know about this later
but the it's the hidden history of the
Kennedy years so this idea of hidden
history I think is sort of what we're
kind of here tonight and what eventually
led to the devil's chessboard I would
say is that correct er yeah that's a
safe statement now it's also one more
thing if I can go onto with the
introduction is that David is also
amidst all these things he's been doing
is also involved in in civic matters
recently with a group called vision SF
and I'm if you've heard of that but if
you haven't you might looked into it and
it has to do with I know for lack of a
better word taking back our city yes
from the 1% as if that's not enough when
do you have time to go to zuni I can
always squeeze that in he's also working
now on or actually it's already going
and it's a new series called hot books
and the first book has come out and it's
called the beast inside the Beast
I'm sorry the beast side the Beast side
saw that dulles stuff picky exactly
living and dying while black in America
and this book is just a fantastic book
and a very important there commentary in
our lives today here in this country and
there's a couple of other books coming
out soon or is that true yeah we can
talk about that later okay so without
further ado let's get to the devil's
chespin
now like the subtitle is allen dulles
the CIA and the rise of America's secret
government so can you tell us how you
got from the brothers to the devil's
chess board well with your permission
Patrick I would just I'm going to start
with a few remarks of my own and then we
get into conversation mode but I wanted
to set the stage by talking about what I
was trying to do with the book it's it's
basically a counter-narrative about
power you know power tells its own story
powers its best publicist power is its
best spinner of the truth and of history
and we've seen this in again and again
throughout our lives people my
generation and many of the people here
Saddam was behind 9/11 Saddam was
producing weapons of mass destruction
the North Vietnamese fired on us ships
in the Gulf of Tonkin Lee Harvey Oswald
single-handedly killed John F Kennedy no
Fidel Castro killed John F Kennedy these
are the stories that power has told
about our itself throughout my lifetime
the essentially these are the real
conspiracy theories and they're told by
power with the complicity of the
American media with corporate media and
these are the stories that have had
unfortunately some tragic consequences
as well as we all know from the examples
that I just cited so it's the job of
people like me
historians alternative historians
journalists to present the truth
basically to cut through this myth
making this spinning of history of
reality and you know it's it's no easy
task because there's Hollywood there's
the corporate media there's Fox News and
again and again day after day 24/7
they're telling us there we
and as Seawright mills the great
sociologist who wrote the power elite
back during the Cold War in the 1950s
and was one of the first to really
analyze the phenomenon of the Dulles
brothers and that power circle as he
famously said about these men such men
as these because they were 99% men in
those days and probably 96% today such
men as these are crackpot realists in
the name of realism or reality they've
created a paranoid reality reality all
of their own and we're forced to live
within that paranoid reality it's the
Communists out to kill us
it's you know people living in a cave
somewhere in Afghanistan there's always
a bogeyman there's always someone that
we have to fear and as a result of that
they've created a lucrative racket and
that's what it is that's that's what
happened during the Cold War that's
what's happening to the war on terror so
it's the job of people like myself it's
the job of of you all of an engaged
citizenry to see through that mythology
to do the work to do the research to
know what's really happening in our
country and make the right decisions by
the end of reading my book and I hope
you read the book I hope you believe as
I do that the name Dulles should go down
and infamy in American history just like
the name Kissinger the name Cheney the
name Rumsfeld
these are names that should be stripped
off the every building every airport
Dulles Airport and replaced with the
names of true American heroes like
Martin Luther King and others and so
tonight I want to announce a campaign to
do exactly that to take the name Dulles
it was named after John Foster Dulles
who has his own criminal background the
brother of Allen Dulles who was
Secretary of State under Eisenhower take
that name off the name of our nation's
capitol the airport where so many people
thousands of people each day come from
around the world it's the Gateway to our
country and it's a name that should
instead as I say go down in infamy and
be replaced by a name that stands for
peace and world harmony
so with that well opening statement
let's have a talk
well one of the things you know is my
water but yes it is okay what I think
they're wondering about is the process
of of doing that of doing the research
of what in doing this book where did you
go and what did you do and and how much
were you aware of initially I've read
the book so if you haven't you will be
you might think you know a lot of of
these stories about the CIA unsettling
government's of assassination of
extraordinary renditions but how did you
where did you go did you travel around
did you meet people who talked did you
go to archives I know Karen Kroft one of
your your partners that did a lot of
work and you were in Italy yep yeah we
did a lot of work Karen Kroft who is my
colleague and collaborator is here
tonight I couldn't have done the book
without her and since the book really
begins with the Nazi period with Allen
Dulles going to Switzerland during World
War Two as a member as a leading you
know agent of the OSS which was our spy
agency during World War two of course
we're dealing with you know history that
is quite old at this point in terms of
trying to find living voices who can
help tell you about that history and of
course we follow sort of the Dulles arc
through World War Two and into the Cold
War and then through the Kennedy period
and it really is an epic narrative about
as I said earlier the struggle which
we've been living through all our lives
between the forces of secrecy of
permanent war and the forces of
democracy and it's really a battle for
the the soul of our nation so yeah many
of the people of course from that era
including Allen Dulles himself of course
is long dead but their children in many
cases are still alive we interviewed
Allen Dulles as daughter Joan we
interviewed some key people who are
still living from that period and of
course we use documents the documents
that we could use now that's a whole
other game of course the government
plays as
Orwell told us in 1984 those who would
control the future control the past and
so it's a struggle for every researcher
for every historian for every journalist
who's trying to dig up the history that
belongs to the American people to get at
those documents and of course the
government often still withholds these
documents what you're also document you
also talk about how they just constantly
were destroying documents
well they destroy documents they hide
them they they refuse they've you know
in violation often a federal law to
release them because of political
pressure there was a bill passed in 1998
under Clinton the Nazi war crimes
disclosure act and I did use many many
documents that were released as part of
that treasure trove but that was only
came about because of stiff political
pressure from Elizabeth Holtzman who was
a congressman at the time and others in
Congress to get the CIA to release these
documents that what because they were
often embarrassing to our intelligence
agencies because what many of these
documents showed and what if my book
goes into an in depth is the extent to
which US security agencies were actually
collaborating with Nazi forces even
during the war in the case of Allen
Dulles in Switzerland and certainly
after the war when we wanted to
repurpose many of these Nazi officials
for the war against the Soviet Union the
Cold War
so yeah it's always a battle sometimes
you have to file for you to move for a
nation act lawsuits even that doesn't
work often they Stonewall you we can
talk about the Kennedy era that's a
whole other story where they again in
violation of federal law the JFK Records
Act that was passed in the early 1990s
still refused to release key documents
related to the Kennedy presidency and
his assassination so it really is up to
the American people to decide whether we
want our own history it belongs to us
are we going to demand it or not I mean
that's what it comes down to but don't
you think at the same time there's this
idea of what you're saying there's this
constant breaking of the law and they
get away with it and Dulles got away
with it
constantly and he made sure he got away
with then also the
the complicity you know between
lawmaking that type of government that
other government and let's say the
private sector because they all came
from Wall Street so we've sort of seen
this kind of complicity but and that
eventually you end up with what you you
call the deep state or maybe that's
Peter Dale Scott's
in the deep state or but this concept of
another guy another operating now this
obviously didn't die with Allen Dulles
do you think no I mean I was leading you
on on that question yeah I mean again
the these forces and what its what see
right mills in the 1950s called the
power lead the it's a permanent
government essentially that operates no
matter who is happens to be elected or
in the White House man like Allen Dulles
thought that democracy was too important
to be left in the hands of mere people
like you and me or our elected
representatives so they kept powers
tightly as they could within their
circle
these were Wall Street right bankers the
Dulles brothers ran the most powerful
law firm on Wall Street Sullivan and
Cromwell they often you know shuttled
back and forth between Washington and
Wall Street in national security
positions and so on high-level corporate
officials military and intelligence
officials they belong to the same clubs
they their children go to the same
schools they intermarry it's a very
cohesive power circle particularly so I
think in those days maybe it's a little
more diverse a little more complex today
than when Seawright Mills was running
the power elite in the late 1950s during
the Dulles era but there's a lot of
cohesion and they work within
organizations like the Council on
Foreign Relations in New York which the
Dulles brothers dominated for many years
and this is where they work out their
ideas and their policies whether it's to
overthrow the democratically elected
government in Guatemala because it's
threatening US corporate interests or
whether it's dropped the bombs nuclear
bombs atomic bombs on Japan or whether
it's to kill a president I think they
work these ideas out among themselves
I'm not suggesting that Alan
some Superman who went about you know
doing all this mischief around the world
and at home all by himself
he was very much a corporate lawyer in
that respect he would only act I think
when he felt that there was a consensus
within that group and so they did have
the mechanisms like the Council on
Foreign Relations and others and they
still do to work out this policy and of
course most of this if not all of it in
many cases has kept secret from the
American people so no and that believes
us here the idea the Fifth Estate now
let's say that like we're always talking
about now how the journalism has it's
more difficult but you know reading your
book it seems that the New York Times
was in their pocket numbers very little
this it seems that dissent was not
didn't really come from not the media is
that the media was not the watchdogs
nice should be and there really wasn't a
watchdog and even though you know you do
point out that even in the highest
circle as a power like within the White
House what these guys were doing their
own thing and they were beyond the law
well but what the media was actually
part of this power circle so I should
say that you know among the other
members of the Council on Foreign
Relations are often the top executives
of the New York Times The Washington
Post CBS and so on and they're all on a
first-name basis a very chemi basis with
Allen Dulles in fact he would hold these
annual kind of drink fests around New
Year's each year where he would invite
the top people top reporters and editors
and executives from these leading media
organizations at his club his club is
called The Alibi Club which was
appropriate and so the it was very cozy
very cozy relationship and so when
people said well certainly these things
would have been exposed by the American
media I mean we have this vast you know
kind of medium apparatus and you know I
always laugh about that as someone who
spent my whole life in the media and
knowing you know how compromised
actually most people in these media
organizations are compromised by power
and you know even
today you know the New York Times was
very complicit of course in the WMD lies
that led tragically to the war in Iraq
and to the ongoing disaster that's going
on in the Middle East today but
certainly back in Allen Dulles is time I
mean you could go into his files as I
did in Karen and I in Princeton and you
know the files are largely purged of
course of you know the most probably
revealing stuff by the CIA but there
still is a lot in there that's very
interesting and among other things are
his very chummy letters back and forth
with these media figures at the New York
Times and Newsweek and so on he's ally
to them I mean you know he has nicknames
for them one letter after the Warren
report came out and he was of course a
very important figure on the Warren
Report some people thought he'd
dominated to the extent that he should
be called the Dulles Commission not the
Warren Commission and after this is a
letter from the Washington bureau chief
I believe of Newsweek to Allen Dulles
after the Warren Report came out saying
dear mr. dolls thank you so much for
directing our coverage basically of the
Warren Commission of the Warren Report
we couldn't have done it under such a
tight deadline without your guiding hand
you know so it's right there to be read
in these files so just to bring it up to
the president so how how is this book
been how do you feel your book has been
positive or been received and can you
talk a little bit about that even in
your hometown they're gobsmacked
it's been interesting I yeah again I
read some of them so I was wondering how
you feel about that because some of them
have been really rather strange I think
well if I hadn't shocked the media I
don't think I would have done my job I
mean you know they are the gatekeepers
they as I start off with my introductory
remarks by saying they have an interest
in telling a certain version about
America and so this is a counter story a
counter narrative and so the yeah
there's been great resistance to the
book from the media gatekeepers I've
been told that
Washington Post it's not gonna review it
but I slipped one by them there and I
actually wrote an op-ed piece that it
did appear in in the Washington Post so
you do it you can do it's guerrilla
warfare I was on my way to al Jazeera
America in a car in Manhattan a week or
so ago on my book tour I was lined up
you know to do a interview in New York
for Al Jazeera America and suddenly my
publicist got a email saying it's been
canceled and when he asked why he was
surprised of course he got a one-word
reply and through the email politics so
they were pretty upfront about it
Politico the online publication started
by former Washington Post people and
it's become sort of the voice online for
mainstream political coverage they had
me lined up to do something one of the
key people there who actually is a very
good reporter called my book a
masterpiece and said that he wanted me
very badly to write something based on
the book for Politico but someone above
him spiked it at the last moment and
instead ran as piece by a guy named Phil
Shannon who was a former New York Times
reporter who has been peddling a CIA
disinformation line for some time now
mainly that Fidel Castro was behind the
murder of President Kennedy which is
literally the oldest conspiracy theory
there is about JFK's assassination and
complete BS so you know that's what
happens it's a war writing is fighting I
didn't excited expect anything different
from this book but the fact is that it's
not a media monolith we people like us
have ways to get the messages out
there's alternative media there's
democracy now there's Pacifica Radio
there's mother jones there's salon which
was why I started salon to have an
alternative voice like that and because
of that the book has now become a
best-seller which I'm very proud of
despite this pushback great yeah that's
what I wanted to hear you saying right
on and it's doing I think it started
taking off Phil in California for some
reason is that correct
the California led the way yeah yes
dollar here first and Northern
California first so this
I don't know this is a silly question or
not but can I ask a possible silly
question of course so it has to do with
the extraordinary rendition so do you in
reading this book I these people the and
the in the effect still of I can see why
you called it the devil's chess board
because they really were playing with
nations with people and the effects so
many of them were deaths suicide nations
in you know crumbled you know a legacy
of ashes as you know the term go so were
you to do guys ever fear for your own
you mean you think I'll end up at
Guantanamo not as a public figures more
difficult these days I don't know I'm
just curious you know this it thought I
even reading it sometimes you think oh
guys creepy well again my might the
point is to have an impact to shift the
public's understanding of what's
happening in our country this is not
just ancient history
this is history that's still very
relevant today extraordinary rendition
torture extra legal assassinations mass
surveillance of private citizens all of
these began not after 9/11 but under the
reign of Allen Dulles back in the Cold
War so for us to understand that Cold
War history is essential for us to
confront what's going on in our country
today
so do I worry about my own self no I
worry about what's still happening to
people in Pakistan people in Afghanistan
to our own soldiers who are asked to
fight these endless wars under
impossible circumstances so that's what
drives me it's it's that this is on my
conscience just is on my soul as an
American as in a journalist and
historian like I know it's on all of our
conscience is here tonight and we have
to say finally enough and it's my job to
give us the information and and there's
other wonderful people out there doing
the same people I worked with it salon
like Glenn Greenwald who's an American
Hero Jeremy Scahill
many others doing the same and that's
why I started this new
book imprint hot books to be able to
publish more books like this that shed
light on what's happening to our country
today but at some point we do have to
say enough you know the presidential
campaign is underway right now and
there's no focus at all on these issues
that Ed Snowden tried to bring forth you
know about the the growth of this Big
Brother state that has intruded into
every aspect of our lives
you know the hearing with Hillary
Clinton with vie Benghazi there was no
mention of what the actual thing was
right there's no talk about why are we
there what what why why why why do they
hate us what is a good question well
exactly I mean we're shocked that people
when we start to have heavy boots in all
these countries and interfere in all
these other countries we're shocked that
actually people fire guns at us in our
emissaries and and try to kill us I mean
this should not be shocking the American
people or that there's atrocities like
the hospital Afghanistan and stand that
was run by Doctors Without Borders that
children and nurses and doctors are
blown up in these attacks that are
supposedly collateral damage well
collateral damage is an essential part
of an imperial situation in Imperial War
that we are constantly fighting that's
what happens in these situations we are
our representatives our soldiers are
killed and to a much greater extent the
civilians in these poor benighted
countries where we've intruded where
we've invaded died by the thousands and
so again this is a legacy of the Allen
Dulles Imperial arrogance of this
country that we have a right to the
world that's what they felt like coming
out of World War two they had a right to
the world we have a right to the world's
markets we have a right to the world's
resources we have a right to do whatever
you want to people around the world who
are less powerful than we are and at
some point we end you know you have to
understand there's going to be blowback
there's going to be consequences
and you know the American people need to
wake up to this and I hope my book is at
least a small part of that
awakening so the let me ask you then
about one of the hot books I think the
topic is about a war criminals yeah but
it is kind of fit right in well right so
hot books is this new imprint I've
started with skyhorse publishing which
is a very brave and independent
publisher in New York run by publisher
named tony lyons and one of our first
books after the beasts side which we
talked about earlier is a book called
american nuremberg and it's been written
by a philosophy professor at USF
University of San Francisco right here
Rebecca Gordon and she wrote a book
earlier for Oxford University Press
called mainstreaming torture that looked
at how we've become culturally you know
a custom now to accepting torture in our
name as part of US policy and this book
she looks at the top US officials in
both the Bush and Obama administrations
from those presidents on down from
President Bush and President Obama
themselves who should by the principles
and standards that were set at Nuremberg
after World War two be tried for war
crimes and it's a very restrained very I
think provocative argument for why we
should hold at least a citizen's
tribunal because politically of course
we know it's impossible to create
something official like Nuremberg
there's just not enough political
opportunity for obvious reasons to do
that in this country but there are
precedents like the Russell Tribunal
that Bertrand Russell British
philosopher established during the
1960's with jean-paul Sartre to examine
war crimes in Vietnam this was a very
distinguished Commission back in 1967
and I think again for the soul of our
country for our own conscience we have
to take steps as as an engaged citizenry
to do something like this to examine
what's been done in the last 15 years
under the so-called war on terror in our
names agree so isn't it you
you tell the story about his district of
Gallinas he sues Diggle in debts yes and
I was wondering if you could just tell
his story because I I wanted to read a
quote that happened after that if you
well so you bring up extraordinary
rendition again nothing new here
this was not an invention of Dick Cheney
and Don Rumsfeld it was actually a
creation of the CIA during the Cold War
so in one of the first cases of
extraordinary rendition that I'm aware
of
it's a remarkable story there was a
young brilliant scholar named hey-zeus
Diggle Indus who was a refugee from
Basque Spain he fled Franco's fascist
government after the war ended up
unfortunately jumping out of the frying
pan into the fire because he ended up in
the Dominican Republic which was then
under the brutal rule of Rafael Trujillo
when he fell afoul of the Trujillo
dictatorship he fled there and ended up
in New York City where he was studying
for his PhD in Colombia and working as a
lecturer at Columbia well he his PhD
thesis was about actually an inside look
because he'd had some inside information
about the brutality of the Trujillo
dictatorship and Trujillo's agents were
everywhere he was a very powerful guy
backed strongly by the Eisenhower
government by the CIA because he was a
supposedly anti-communist that's all you
had to be in those days to get us
backing and his agents stalked Glenda's
in New York City they showed up his
classrooms and tried to intimidate him
they tried to threaten him into stopping
you know seizing work on his thesis but
he refused and so one day he was headed
home
downtown from Columbia and he was
grabbed by agents who actually went
under the employ of the CIA
these were CIA contractors he was
hustled to airport in on Long Island and
flown back to the Dominican Republic
where he was horribly tortured and
murdered by Trujillo so this is what
extraordinary
and this happened in the 1950s not you
know after the 9/11 indent I guess
this is from your book when you're
student of the students from Columbia
who I think his name was joy was your
new Maria joy one of his students yeah
yeah and she wrote if this can happen
here what is left everybody who has some
sense of responsibility and a feeling
for democracy and freedom should be
concerned and I thought that is what
your book is all about yeah that was
absolutely I thought that was a very
moving letter that she wrote I think to
the New Republic was a New Republic yeah
in trying to get people to be concerned
about this case because at that point
they didn't know where Gulen just had
gone he'd been disappeared but of course
they had suspicions about it what had
happened to him and the eyes and how
actually even President Eisenhower has
asked about his disappearance during a
press conference and he kind of avoided
answering Columbia University was kind
of complicit in a way because the
president Grayson Kirk at the time was
sat on commissions and and foundations
that were supported by the CIA the
Columbia administration did nothing to
look into the Glenda's case so you know
it's again one of these dark episodes
from the CIA history that we write about
in The Devil's chess board but again I
just think that this concern is why
we're all here and why you do what you
do and I also want to say you know ask
you what what is new that you really
what's the newest thing that you found
out in doing that that you found most
relevant ori well I think that the key
sort of headlines from my book began
with the Nazi period began with the
extent to which Allen Dulles and his
circle his intelligence circle
collaborated with the Nazis before in
the case of Sullivan and Cromwell the
wall street law firm because they
represented Nazi business interests
including IG Farben the notorious
chemical company that produced zyklon-b
the pesticide that was used to
exterminate Jews and you know they're
exchanging Christmas cards the Dulles
brothers with the heads of up IG Farben
up into actually into the early
or period Delos from his perch in
Switzerland during the war continued to
represent Nazi interests he was trying
to cut deals side deals in defiance of
Roosevelt policy of unconditional
surrender with Nazi emissaries separate
peace deals after the war he helps
establish the so-called rat lines that
were escape routes for Nazi war
criminals that were set up so they could
flee from Germany over the Alps down
through Italy and overseas to safety he
even helped rehabilitate some of the
more notorious Nazi war criminals
allowing them to go back into daily life
even official life in West Germany
post-war Germany the top spy master in
West Germany tell the story is Reinhard
Galen who was Hitler's top spy master on
the bloody Eastern Front and Allen Dells
helped install him as the top
intelligence official in West German
government he would played a very
important role in the Cold War for many
years so that's number one the
collaboration with the Nazis I argue in
some ways that we didn't crush the Third
Reich so much as repurpose it for the
Cold War secondly there's a lot of
things in the Cold War period that I go
into that haven't come out before
including the fact that we targeted not
only governments in Guatemala which we
know about Iran which was with great
disastrous results that we're still
dealing with today but even the the
government of an ally President Charles
de Gaulle in France antagonized national
security interests in this country in
Dulles in particular by trying to settle
the war in Algeria the colonial war u.s.
national security interests were
concerned they thought that Algeria and
North African with its oil might fall
into Soviet hands as a result they
thought de Gaulle was too stubborn a
nationalist he was flirting with the
idea of breaking away from NATO and so
on and so in 1961 on the heels of the
one other CIA crisis the Bay of Pigs
invasion of Cuba young President Kennedy
who's just been inaugurate
a couple months before is now faced with
another crisis related the CIA Charles
DeGaulle
and his government are furious are
screaming that the CIA is backing a
right-wing French military coup against
him and President Kennedy has put in an
extremely awkward position of telling
the de Gaulle government well I'm not in
control of the CIA I can't speak for
them I'm not supporting this coup but
I'm not in the CIA and then finally I
think the the big headline of course in
my book that's getting a lot of pushback
from the media gatekeepers looks at
Allen Dulles as involvement in the
Kennedy assassination itself de Gaulle
by the way felt that these Dulles forces
were behind the assassination of
President Kennedy
he told us information minister when he
came back from the funeral of John
Kennedy that the same national security
forces in the u.s. that targeted me
killed President Kennedy that has never
been really reported in this country
that book has never even been translated
it was a memoir by de Gaulle's
information minister that he wrote that
was published in France never translated
in the US so that's very important
I present I think very compelling new
evidence that ties Dulles to the
assassination and of course to the
cover-up because he played such a
critical role on the Warren Commission I
mean how convenient this guy had been
fired by President Kennedy after the Bay
of Pigs a bitter enemy of the President
ends up being the top investigator into
his crime into his murder I mean this is
the way that this power group worked
with again the complicity or laziness of
the American media absolutely maybe we
want to turn it over to that I would say
you know so let's have a big hand for
David thank you
and we'd like to know if you want to do
a little Q&A here if you do if you could
come up and talk into the microphone
that would be great and we also would
like to make sure it's a question and
not a statement if that's possible
I know people sort of save a statement
at the end but so anybody like to come
out of a mm-hmm you need to come up and
talk if you want to ask
I just noticed what came out was along
with your book was about another rerun
of Gary Webb and I was wondering if
you'd like to talk about connections
across those two so the question was
about the journalist Gary Webb who wrote
the Dark Alliance was that what was
called yeah as a reporter for the San
Jose Mercury he investigated the
connection between CIA in the Contras in
Central America and how they allowed the
Contras to run drugs into this country
to help finance their activities there
and it was a bombshell when that story
broke he came under heavy fire from the
CIA as a result of it and heavy pressure
ultimately from his own newspaper and
from the American media that kind of
went after him instead of pursuing the
story itself and he ended up being you
know his career end up being ruined and
it was I think one of the great
tragedies of American journalism that
here's you know one of the great truth
tellers one of the brave investigative
journalists and you know instead of
winning out the awards that he should
have won his career was a ruin that he
ended up actually committing suicide so
the
there you know I I was at salon at the
time I think one of the great regrets I
have actually is not being tuned in
enough to that story as it was happening
to hire Gary Webb and put him to work
because those kind of talented and
intrepid journalists are far too few it
and I would have loved to have given him
another safety raft and when I saw
better but read about his story by
because it was written by by nicholas
scow who was actually a very good
reporter kill the messenger it later
became a great movie with jeremy renner
starring as Gary Webb you should all see
the movie and read the book in fact
because of Karen Kroft I signed up
Nicholas Scout to write a book for me
for the hot book series well I'll tell
you badly
you're on a need-to-know basis Patrick
yeah it's still it's still in you know
kind of a high shush mode Oh cut that
out anyway yes so Gary Webb is a hero
and unfortunately it's not what this any
longer
and I'm inspired by what he did in part
by what I've done with the devil's chess
board that's great I'm glad if the
people are making that connection nobody
else like to come up and ask a question
you can come up and ask so you're asking
if Gary Webb did indeed commit suicide
yeah there's definitely some some you
know ways about the way he's supposedly
committed suicide that have raised
questions I I'm sorry sir I just don't
know enough about the details to go into
it so much oh look we'll leave it there
other questions here yeah if presidents
don't have the power the power somewhere
else then how could we as citizens have
a criminal
who would we take take against this
Criminal Court you know how do we get to
the power not butcher Obama but the real
power so that's that's a very you've put
your finger on the key question how do
we go about holding these people
accountable we are in democracy
nominally and how do we go about acting
as if the the popular will the public
will matters so as I said earlier you
know obviously we don't control Congress
every wing of the government is in
support of the war on terror every wing
of government is in support of
suppressing our own history of not
releasing documents that the American
people have a right to we probably are
in the worst situation right now than we
were even in some ways during the Cold
War because of the sort of you know
reign of terror and repression that 9/11
unleashed so what we can do is
unfortunately I think we have to do
outside of the mainstream political
arena we have to I think be inspired as
I said earlier by things like the
Bertrand Russell Commission during the
Vietnam War I think that would be an
amazing you know step forward if we
could bring together legal scholars some
people from the political system
investigative journalists experts and
constitutional law and so on and bring
them together for an for this public
inquiry into you know the war on terror
and the crimes that have been committed
in our name and and and and you know
organize us in such a way that it got
maximum media exposure and you know
various public organizations
hopefully human rights groups
participate in this I think that would
at least begin the national dialogue
that we're missing in the presidential
campaign I mean these issues aren't
being discussed at all even by Bernie
Sanders as far as I'm can go Bernie has
done a wonderful job of focusing on the
wealth gap which is another you know
enormous crisis for the country and I
you know obviously we you know we have
to commend him for doing that that was
desperately needed also that national
discussion but the national discussion
about the permanent war that we're in
and whenever you're in a permanent war
situation it's gonna it's going to erode
democracy at home you can't have those
two things existing at the same time
because a national security state is
anathema to a democracy to a healthy
democracy so there's no way that
Congress is going to do this on its own
we have to act as if we created this
public commission the public inquiry in
Washington DC to shame Congress and to
get as much media exposure as we could
it would at least initiate this national
discussion that we sorely need at this
point with regard to a national security
state being inconsistent with the
democracy last night on Charlie Rose Ted
Koppel up here talking about the
possibility of internet sabotage and
this kind of thing do you have any
comments to make about that I think
that's the beginning he seems to be
launching a campaign to raise
consciousness about this this problem
and I I personally don't think the
national security state is going to go
away anytime soon
I wonder if you have any thoughts on
Koppel's campaign well I'm not clear
about what he's doing is he trying to
suggest that the Internet is a terrorist
tool and we have to crack down on some
matter
right that so they always have some new
scare for us you know some new thing
that we have to hide under the beds and
worry about all right so you know Ted
Koppel I think as part of that corporate
media that national security media he
has been his whole career what's
shocking is when some of these guys
actually start to break away from that
consensus you know Dan Rather gave me a
shout out dan Rather was part of that
you know sort of corporate mainstream
world for many years and then of course
had his own kind of traumatic break with
it following the story he did on Bush
and the National Guard and as a result
he was fired by CBS and so now he's been
in the wilderness for some time and he
gave he was good enough to give me a
shout-out for the devil's chess board
and said you know you've been telling
the truth for a long time now and so
that was great to hear from him
unfortunately it happens for some of
these people after they're sort of like
you know thrown overboard I wish it
happened while they were actually in
positions of power and we could they
could do more you know to enlighten the
American people but yeah I don't believe
what kept Ted Koppel says I don't
believe what Charlie Russell Charlie
Rose rather you know his point of view
either these are very mainstream people
they're not about shaking up you know
the national conversation they're about
putting America to sleep which he often
does for me
I finished a book this summer by L
Fletcher Prouty the secret team and I
was curious he seems to suggest that the
Fletcher patties that proud of yes the
secret team he seems it's just that the
1947 National Security Act seems to have
given the CIA their their power or
whatever and how do you feel about maybe
changing that I know changing the names
on airports and everything would be good
but maybe something that really took
something away from them such as that
yeah so L Fletcher Prouty was a Air
Force officer and an American Hero you
know the American military has a number
of these people throughout our histories
thankfully Smedley darling but Butler
how many people know this medley bark
Darlington Butler's name the famous
marine hero who actually became a great
champion of peace and democracy and
Fletcher Prouty is another military hero
and people should read his books he's
not with us any longer but he wrote
extensively about how the national
security state was eroding democracy and
when in fact was in a great position to
see this happen because he was the
liaison at one point between the Air
Force and Allen Dulles CIA so he knew
Allen Dulles quite well 1947 is the year
that the CIA is created in the national
security you know
charters passed Harry Truman is
president
he later felt came to feel that he
created a Frankenstein and I think proud
he probably believed the same but this
was the President himself who was saying
this he always intended he said Truman
for the CIA to be nothing more than an
intelligence gathering organization that
would then collate the best information
and pass it on to the president in the
White House but instead it became this
this action arm that went around the
world overthrowing governments and
assassinating people and so on and Harry
Truman wrote a remarkable op-ed piece
about this and
Chintan post shortly after President
Kennedy was killed and it really was a
bombshell at the time given the kind of
traumatized State of the Nation then
just weeks after Dallas and what he
wrote in the Washington Post was that
yes that the CIA was had become this
kind of rogue agency and that was not
only endangering democracies overseas
but at home so Allen Dulles was stunned
by this and he knew he couldn't let it
stand so he immediately goes into action
he tries to strong-arm Harry Truman
who's now around 80 years old retired in
Independence Missouri he tries to
pressure Truman into withdrawing
retracting his own article you know what
Truman's a stubborn guy famously and and
refuses so Dulles flies down to Missouri
and personally again puts the pressure
on him and says mr. president you
certainly remember that when you created
the CIA you wanted it to be this
activist agency and so on Truman won't
hear anything of that and it stands by
his article so Dulles does the next best
thing he can't change reality so what
does he do and this is how of course
intelligence agencies operate all the
time they changed the record so he
writes a letter for the record Dulles to
the general counsel of the CIA and says
oh I just came back from visiting Harry
Truman you know he was very upset to
hear that his article had been read that
way he didn't mean to say that he was
confused about how it actually had come
through that way he made him out to be
in other words this senile guy who
didn't know what he was doing maybe some
deputy had put him up to it
and so on so that's became the CIA's
official story he got picked up in
various histories and various essays
written by ci family historians and so
on so Allen Dulles was a master at that
at manipulating the truth when the truth
didn't satisfy his needs
you obviously command a huge amount of
information related to the Dulles era
and especially the Kennedy assassination
and all of the enormous literature
that's come out of it
and the credibility of that material is
spotty shall we say and I'm just curious
there's um the the story that's always
sort of alleged about the plot to sort
of involve Cuba more deeply in the
assassination of John Kennedy but yet a
very few bits of information have ever
surfaced trying to make that connection
more tangible that you mean the
allegation that Fidel Castro's behind
the assassination or that that there was
some complicity there um and I came
across a book a few years ago that was
is the only source that I know that
really talks about that's called JFK the
second plot by a guy named Matthew Smith
published in the England and I'm just
curious to know are you familiar with it
I'm not know what's he say basically
that the sheriff of the adjoining County
to Dallas actually has the wing numbers
of the airplane that was sitting idling
on the runway at the time of the
assassination with a flight plan to Cuba
and the allegation was that Oswald
Ursula's did fly there yes and there's
there's a whole series of connections
about how the he was supposed to be
transported you know to the airport that
the the sheriff seems to corroborate so
I just thought that was kind of an
interesting tidbit then I kept looking
for him your book I just finished it
about days ago okay well I can't comment
specifically on the book unfortunately
cuz I haven't read it but I will come in
I think it's very important on this long
you know complicated you know allegation
that Fidel Castro in Cuba was somehow
involved in
assassination of President Kennedy I
think it's you know to be blunt about it
it's the oldest lie that's been told
about the Kennedy assassination and in
fact it was being disseminated that lie
was a disinformation line by the CIA and
its friendly assets in the American
media and the world media while the
president's body was still warm that was
the first conspiracy theory being pumped
out about the Kennedy assassination and
here's why it was preposterous I'll go
into seven of the just key things at the
very moment when President Kennedy was
being shot in Dallas he's meeting with a
peace envoy Castro from JFK the French
journalist John Danielle who's carrying
an olive branch from Kennedy now this is
one of several peace and voice who on
the President's request has gone down to
Havana to try and find a way finally to
defuse the tension between Havana and
Washington and as soon as the message is
delivered in Havana they find out that
the assassination the Castro is
devastated because he now realizes these
peace these back-channel peace
negotiations are finished and he says to
you know John Danielle this is terrible
basically everything's changed and then
he says now watch the next thing we'll
know will hear is that they're pinning
it on me and of course that's exactly
the next broadcast from America is
connecting Lee Harvey Oswald to Cuba
through the fair play for Cuba committee
you know the bridge of spies film by
Spielberg leaves one key thing out a new
film it's a you know entertaining movie
with Tom Hanks and so on and it's about
this guy who is an American Hero James
Donovan he was a New York corporate
attorney who was recruited by Kennedy to
go to Berlin to you know to win the
release of Francis Gary Powers in return
for the release of a Soviet spy and it's
a great story but he it's presented as
if he's doing this pretty much on his
own like he's a lone ranger and as I
wrote in my op-ed piece recently in The
Washington Post this actually you know
very delicate diplomatic dance had the
complete support of Khrushchev in Moscow
and Kennedy
Washington because both of these world
leaders were actually trying to defuse
the Cold War and this was one of the
first steps in that direction now they
also leave out the fact there's a little
crawl at the end of the movie saying oh
later Jim Donovan was used by Kennedy to
win the release of the Bay of Pigs
prisoners in Cuba which is true but
there's an even more interesting story
about Jim Donovan and Kennedy in Cuba
which is that after he won the release
of the Bay of Pigs prisoners the Kennedy
brothers asked Dimon again to widen his
efforts in Cuba and to establish a
broader peace understanding with Castro
and he went down on more than one
occasion hit it off with Castro they
were both were drinkers they'd love to
talk Donovan and Fidel late into the
night and he was on the verge of a you
know forging a rapprochement with Havana
but the CIA was not in support of this
and when they got word of this
back-channel that Kennedy had set up
with Havana they actually went to DOM
and said hey on your next trip to Cuba
we understand that Fidel is a scuba
enthusiast why don't you take him this
wetsuit which he will enjoy putting on
well the wetsuit of course was infused
with poisons cooked up in the CIA labs
this is a famous story of course that
one of the many ways that the CIA tried
to kill Castro was with the poison
wetsuit so here's the CIA in one of the
many cases in which it tried to sabotage
Kennedy policy and the Kennedy policy
aimed at ending the Cold War with Moscow
and Havana and this is one of the most
flagrant ways using a peace emissary as
peace envoy who was an American Hero to
try and kill Castro unwittingly
so it's a remarkable story and you know
the CIA's effort to blame Castro for
what I believe actually came out of the
anti-castro plot against Kennedy as
Bobby Kennedy figured out immediately as
Attorney General and I write about it
this in both my books brothers and
devil's chess board that's the source of
the plot not Castro himself
it's the anti-castro operation that's
being run by the CIA with the Mafia's
help
that's the blowback that killed
kay and you know Fidel Castro had
nothing to do with JFK's assassination
it's sort of like a forest for the trees
discussion I mean I'm really awestruck
by the minutiae in the detail that you
provide which really makes it you know
show don't tell but to me this don't you
think that the collaboration begins
before World War two and that the
national security state was actually
born out of World War one and the whole
creation of Nazi Germany is a feature of
u.s. foreign policy and that this entire
endless war machine is much older than
World War two I mean if you could yeah
no you're right and for simplicity I
kind of focus on in the book with the
World War two period and with Delos
slipping across the border into
Switzerland but I do allude to some of
the earlier history as well and you're
right for instance Sullivan and Cromwell
they're Wall Street law firm the Dulles
brothers firm was really made fortune
off of being sort of at the center of
the reparations a game that was going on
at the time you know to rebuild Germany
and that's where they start to embed
themselves in these German corporate
interests and when Hitler comes on the
scene they just sort of seamlessly go
with him
as the person who's rebuilding Germany
as the regime but yeah it goes back to
World War one I mean really you could
say speaking of Smedley Butler it goes
back to the turn of the century when the
American Empire first is created in the
spanish-american war and the Philippines
and Cubans so on and those Banana
Republic the wars that America was
fighting you know Smedley Butler who is
this marine hero who's Forrest as a
young marine to fight in all these dirty
Wars these imperial wars throughout the
Caribbean and Central America and so on
you know said later I wasn't fighting
for Uncle Sam
I was fighting for Wall Street and you
know you know he said he was a the
bigger gangster basically then
Capone so and he said war is a racket
you know he wrote a book war is a racket
so you know he was drawing on his
experience from wars that really were
starting at the turn of the century
around 1900 and that Mark Twain among
others another great American hero was
crusading against inroad again saying
America was going down a very dark path
and I wrote a book actually kind of a
graphic history illustrated by the great
Spain Rodriguez the the late cartoonists
in Spain I worked on that that tried to
bring you know the butler Smedley Butler
story to a younger audience so yes there
is more history there devil dog do you
have that Patrick I thought you were a
Talbot completest any other question
thank you can you talk about angleton as
a cultural czar I think you called him
and if I can sink in a second question
Dulles is a whole kind of world and
milieu is deception and lies how do you
how do you work through that and come to
something that seems to be as endless of
the truth in doing research yeah good
question so James Jesus Angleton how
many people know that name legendary
chief of counterintelligence and the
leading intellectual sir an artist
really an artist of artists of deceit
and covert action so he was Allen Dulles
his right-hand person they go way back
together they start working together
really during World War Two the final
days of the war where they're very
active in Rome James Angleton has some
deep roots in Italy his family he prided
himself on being very connected there
and that sort of spy versus spy
atmosphere in Rome right after the war
is fascinating and I try and evoke that
period you know one of the things I
tried to do by the way was write an anti
spy novel basically I wanted to grip the
reader and I think the book really does
pull you along with all these
amazing stories but they're all true and
so angleton is this amazing character
and one of the things he's doing in Rome
is setting up these rat lines to allow
the Nazis to escape and he sets up a
kind of a luxury apartment in Rome for
some of the more notorious and
flamboyant Nazis and so he you know he
has a lot of deep history with Dulles
and in fact he later said he suggested
at the end of his life that the reason I
became so successful within the CIA was
basically I had the goods on Allen
Dulles and he had to keep promoting me
and so that's an interesting thing he
also was a Catholic so he had something
of a conscience kind of a soiled
conscience and as he was dying from all
the cigarettes he had smoked over the
years and he was wracked by coughs and
lung cancer at the end you know he said
the heads of the CIA the great legends
of the CIA like Allen Dulles and Richard
Helms were all going to end up in hell
he told a journalist who was visiting
him and he said I imagine I'll be seeing
them there shortly
he was this artist in a way though as
you suggest at Yale he published a very
well-respected poetry journal he knew
Ezra Pound and hung out with the EE
Cummings and he you know he understood
that the Cold War was very very much a
war of ideas and a culture war and so
under Angleton and his deputies within
the CIA they pumped a fortune in two
different front groups the cultural
front organizations that subsidized
poets and poetry journals and
conferences literary conferences and
magazines including some of the more
famous ones Paris review and so on
encounter magazine so he understood this
war as an a war of ideas an intellectual
war and that and he was able to create I
think a very strong cultural hegemony
within sort of the intelligentsia in
this country and in Western Europe
and you broke away from that a great
peril to your career really you mean
suddenly funds would dry up you didn't
get teaching positions you know it was
very effective so Stalin you know in the
Soviet Union maybe had more brutal
methods of controlling intellectuals and
artists but certainly the Western Way
the angleton Way was almost even more
effective in some ways because it was
full of self it was driven by
self-censorship
and a sense that we didn't want to break
away as an artist from this Cold War
consensus so the few people who did at
the time were heroes I think and one of
the ones that I highlight my book was
Searight Mills who when I was in college
was you know very well known figure
because of his book the power elite but
it's been largely forgotten now but you
know he was a critic of these cold war
intellectuals he said basically you're
all about American triumphalism and in
celebrating America and you that's not
the role of an intellectual the role of
an intellectual is to be rigorously
independent and critique power and
you've all sold out and intellectuals
like Arthur Schlessinger liberals who
were among the most compromised by
Angleton and his cultural funding were
furious at people like Mills and so
there were great debates between mills
and Schlesinger sadly you know Mills
after championing the Cuban Revolution
he wrote a big bestseller called listen
Yankee he went down to Cuba and hung out
with Fidel and che in the early days he
died very young I think it was late 40s
in 1962 I think it was one more
so I think a lot of your audience here
today came out either inclined to
believe your particular
counter-narrative or with a
counter-narrative of their own that they
wanted to put to you as someone who
simply wandered in because the topic
seemed interesting you use two terms in
describing the book one is a
counter-narrative which i think means
something intended to question the
common erred if the other one is a true
story which means something else
entirely
especially for a historian why is the
you know the let's say georgetown
political science student or the MIT
computer science student somebody who's
educated who has an idea of what logic
is but who may not be an expert in the
subject why what why should they take
yours to be the true story that's a good
question
and you really have to read the black
you know not just listening tonight to
look at the evidence that I compiled and
the argument that I put together you
know I think speaking bar through
Schlessinger I think it was less than
true said history is an ongoing argument
and I understand that my book will be
challenged from many directions and it
is being challenged and you know the
people who have their own ideological
bias that I can see right away that are
trying to knock this story down I
dismiss those but I take to heart
actually people who have done their own
work and have researched this history as
exhaustively as I have and so I often
learn from these dialogues with them you
know whether it's on the internet or
face-to-face I understand I didn't get
everything right I didn't get the whole
story perhaps but I really do think this
is the work of my lifetime and Karen
Kroft and I worked very hard on this
we've been working basically for about
ten years on this when you look at both
my book brothers and this book and I
think this book is the most complete
version of this history that we have at
this point I expect it to you know as I
say to be challenged and to
maybe overtime but as of the Year 2015
if you want a real understanding of what
happened in the Cold War to this nation
and the rise of the secret government
and how democracy was undermined and how
people were killed heroes who defied
that secret state then I think you have
to read my book great that's a great way
to end I want to let you know too that
David will be at the Howard Zinn Book
Festival which is November 15th that
mission branch of City College thank you
David
Thank You Patrick thank you Karen thank
you concerned citizens and please I'll
be signing books yes but I get some
books and wait should I be get them
signed when you'll stay there
the names and loss evidence unless it's
a passing interest